in the city of Sarasota people avoided a
direct hit by Hurricane Ian but they
still felt the power of its brutal force
Ed mccrane is the Emergency Management
chief of Sarasota County good morning Ed
how are you doing
good morning thank you a very good uh
fortunately we were blessed uh
unfortunately your friends to the South
were hurt pretty bad
yeah well thank you for joining us what
is the situation in Sarasota County
right now
like I said we were blessed the storm
surge did not materialize on our Coast
like we had planned for and that's good
uh bad news is it went into Charlotte
Harbor so our partners to the South and
Charlotte and Lee got hit we have no
damage uh so to speak on our beaches our
biggest impact was Northport the city of
Northport and maybe part of Inglewood uh
Northport is along our River we are
having a lot of difficulty getting to
certain places because the water levels
are so high so we're getting high water
vehicles and boats the sun is starting
to come up soon and we'll have a better
idea of what the damage is there but for
the most part
minimal compared to what I'm hearing
happened in Fort Myers and those areas
that's good to hear that it did not hit
you as as expected always like when that
happens what's your biggest concern your
biggest priority right now are you still
going to wait and see exactly what we're
dealing with
well we've got a few major issues
Inglewood Hospital in our South County
was in the a b Zone uh they did not
evacuate and now they have a lot of
damage they've got some flooding uh I
know that we're working with the state
and the Department of Health to get them
uh really it's those patients reload
relocated evacuated out of there when
the daylight hours will probably see a
lot of helicopter activity assisting
with that and ambulance Strike Team city
of Northport a lot of flooding it's
typical down there it's just on the
geography and the water flows we'll have
a lot of issues with residents being
able not to get out of their home
because of the water they were not
necessarily in an evacuation area but
the river came to meet them so to speak
we have several shelters there that are
surrounded by water we're trying to get
access to but we have not had any
reports of any injuries we did have some
structural damage to a couple of our
shelters down there roofs came off in
certain sections of the campus but not
necessarily where the people were being
sheltered but that's understandable with
a 150 mile an hour eye wall that
basically went through there last night
so we're fortunate but we still have
some damage I told the state director
once we get a handle on what we need to
do we'll assign people to deal with that
and whatever we have left over will join
the fight and help in Lee County
oh that was going to be my follow-up
question there you know while you're
talking the pictures next to you on the
screen are from Fort Myers just across
from Inglewood not far at all and you
say a narrow Miss there for Sarasota
County but it looks very bad indeed just
across the bay there what are you
hearing actually about the conditions
and the needs of your neighbors to the
South
I'm hearing hundreds and hundreds of
people that are going to need temporary
Sheltering
um and movement to a safe location so
that's what you're going to probably see
happening the state is mobilizing uh the
state directors sending every assets the
National Guard command element that was
in my EOC for the last couple nights
when I got up this morning they were
gone so I imagine that they're
mobilizing their 1100 National Guardsmen
and women to go uh down south and assist
with search and rescue operations with
traffic control with feeding so it's
going to be a big operation the major
impact of this is going to be Lee County
in the southern part of Charlotte and
I'm also concerned about Inglewood even
though they are in the Charlotte County
side Inglewood is a town it's not really
a
shitty or whatever but it's one of our
areas that is in both counties uh their
part in Charlotte is primarily Coastal
the capaze peninsula and uh there's even
a small piece of Lee County that sticks
out off that Cape paste Peninsula called
Boca Grande you may be familiar with
that so um that's going to be a a good
thing to see how bad that was hurt
because I know they got a lot of storm
surge of course
Ed we appreciate you thank you for
joining us and allowing us to understand
how extreme extreme this storm is we
appreciate you